[Music]  now I'm sure you've all heard the huge  news JJ Abrams will be directing the  next chapter of the Star Wars saga and  the perfect guy to do it but here is  more big news this morning they  announced we'll be directing the next  Star Wars porn parody yeah in fact  here's some footage from the press  conference check it out I promise you  this next chapter will honor the  tradition of the early Star Wars films  you grew up spanking it too with this  next Star Wars picture we're going to be  heading it's a much darker territory in  fact you might say we're heading  somewhere the Sun doesn't shine I'm  referring to the but what the fans to  know all that favorite characters will  be there  han Solo Chewbacca Luke skank wanker a  c3p fruit of course all we want to blow  me watch you will not see Jar Jar boys  so I'm what you got boys  [Applause]  [Music]  that's horrible  yeah kinda icky yeah yeah can't wait to  see it